welcome to another episode of not too
deep I'm your host grace and Helbig the
first we got nick colletti here with us
today
he's a Viner he's a real bro of Simi
Valley he's an aspiring stand-up
comedian look out Dave Chappelle he's
coming for you
he will you inspired him very much and
I'm his sister's a fan so hi Rach was it
I think hey girl thanks for listening
and watching enjoy this episode with
nick colletti I'm not too deep this
episode is brought to you by our dear
dear friends at Squarespace turn your
great idea into a reality with
Squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project
whether you're showcasing your work or
selling products of any kind with
beautiful templates and the ability to
customize just about anything you can
easily make a beautiful website oh but
yourself but if you do get stuck
Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support is there to help so
head to squarespace.com slash Grace for
a free trial and when you are ready to
launch use the offer code grace to save
10% off your first purchase of the
website or domain yeah it's happening
nick colletti grace Helbig I'm so
excited that you're here thank you I cut
you off you were telling me a story
before we started and you so wonderfully
said should I save this for the podcast
and I said you're a genius mm-hmm you
want to hear the story I'm ready so I
yeah I told my sister today I was like
um they were like what are you doing
today and I was like I'm just gonna have
like an interview on this podcast and my
sister was like who is it and I was like
grace Helbig and she was like oh my god
like she freaked out your sister younger
older younger sweetie
still hitting that young demo she she
was like really really surprised well no
she's like a huge fan so she was like oh
my god yeah do you only have one sister
mm-hmm oh very and you talk to her
regularly yeah Rach wait she's my buddy
hey Rach thanks sir listening or
watching anything that goes up on the
Internet ready Joe also to my brother
who doesn't listen to this and that I
should
call more regularly um maybe I'll reach
out yeah you should I'm inspired now
send them some memes every once in a
while oh yeah that's what I do
thank memes like check out send a meme
okay um
Nick you're in the real boroughs of Simi
Valley yes which is so fun because I'm a
huge reality television junkie thank you
and I love your Housewives all of them
do you watch reality television I do
watch The Bachelor sometimes my
girlfriend really yeah what are you
watching this season yeah I've watched
episode last night I haven't caught up
yet this is a little boring to me that's
what she was saying - I don't I've
realized I watched did you guys watch
the last season she did with Becky
Rebecca I realized that watching women
fight for a man is uncomfortable for me
to watch versus watching men fight for a
women I just feel like so sad for them
like the women that I'm just like I
can't feel gross watching this yeah
which I you know reality TV is generally
kind of gross so I don't know why all
the sudden it's hitting me maybe this is
what like maturing feels like yeah did
you watch any Real Housewives before
doing real bros no no maybe a couple
snippets here and there I have I had
like a general idea of what the show
sure I didn't know like you know the ins
and outs of the show yeah because we
talked to Jimmy about it and he even
said that once he watched her Housewives
it wasn't really like that they wanted
to make it more like Vanderpump rules
would just I mean they're all the same
essentially most Vanderpump rules Oh get
ready ask your girlfriend she'll
definitely know it's basically about a
bunch of servers that work at this
restaurant in West Hollywood okay and
like the you know the community sexual
encounters and whatever that happens oh
yeah
it's all very meshed yeah Vanderpump
rules is just about servers that work in
a restaurant that all somehow get in
relationships with each other in various
degrees so in West Hollywood in West
Hollywood you can go to the restaurant I
have been there what sir
yes you are it's answer sexy unique
restaurant
SoDo that's [ __ ] awesome I love it ok
wait how did you get involved in real
bros I actually like I think kind of
just just kind of happened me and me and
Tanner who plays Bryce on the show where
it was when all the suds stuff was
happening for anybody who doesn't know
what side it is it's just like we just
said sided basically and so yeah we were
actually in a skit of his and he must
have liked you know the chemistry we
kind of were all like just chill so he
asked us to come in and read it we
didn't even have to audition he kind of
just had us in mind oh yeah yeah the
part so we just did the table read shot
the first season and then now it's like
slowly I mean slowly kind of evolving
into this bigger thing yeah because you
were big on fine for a long time
rest in peace fine it'll be back still
do say I feel like it'll be back how did
you get into making vines um
I don't know my friend my friend kind of
just showed me the app one day alright
at first I didn't really like it I was
like this is kind of dumb yeah cuz I to
be fair I don't let people [ __ ] on vine
but I can't do it I tried so many times
when it came out to be like I guess I
gotta get on behind and figure this out
and I couldn't my brain could not work
in six seconds and to people that have
such a presence on there had such a
presence I give you lots of credit I
could not like why can't I do this is so
impossible from my side of the coin I
can't do it you do which is like
long-form stuff because I can't yeah I
can only focus for six seconds but but
so then you started doing that where
were you in the world when you started
doing that were you already in LA back
in Pittsburgh back in Pittsburgh from
right Terrible Towels all of that right
sorry about Super Bowl and everything
it's a hard cool yeah I'm sorry to bring
up too terrible things vine anything
else geez and we can talk about you know
the falling of our like political system
if we
get into that should we I was thinking
about that I was like if she owned her
she's gonna ask no no it's called not
too deep we do not get into politics or
religion yeah I mean that's the extent
of how much we get into politics good
okay so you were doing this in
Pittsburgh were you doing it by yourself
your friend showed you the app yeah my
friend Adam Adam Adam bussy Adam bussy
it's a great name one of my best friends
um yeah he showed me and he I remember
seeing Jerome Jay remember him Jerome
Jarre yeah Jerome Jarre my friend he was
like yeah the friendship is like it's
Esquivel but he showed me that guy and
he was like dude this guy's like just he
has so many followers he's just making
these little videos like we could do
this yeah and that's when I kind of
click for me and so I started just going
like super ham like probably posting
like two or three times a day for like
two years
oh wow he didn't end up doing it yeah
which is fine but yeah but I like kind
of took it and ran with it and then now
it's yeah it's like my career was kind
of like this that's great did you ever
before that where you did you have any
plans or ideas of like doing
entertainment doing comedy doing that
sort of thing
yeah I mean yeah from like a really
young age I think I knew that's why I
like I didn't really sweat high school I
didn't go to like a traditional college
cuz I kind of knew what I wanted to do
like yeah as a kid that's great you
saved a lot of money that way yeah and
then so then when did you make the move
to Los Angeles because remember we had
sane and heath on a while ago and they
kind of have a similar story that
they're just in Florida found this app
start making vines and then like one
thing leads to another
yeah what was it for you um it wasn't I
was 19 years old I moved out it was what
2013-2014 okay but yeah it was just when
I had enough actually no it really
wasn't I mean I think I had a million on
vine which was okay but I
wasn't like making money off of it at
this point right um so I kind of just
said you know like this is my I'm gonna
do I'm gonna take this leap of faith and
see what happens like I just
my parents were you know like you know
we'll see what happens yeah they
supportive enough yeah they were but I
definitely could tell that they were
like okay like if you can't make it you
can come back like but I was like I'm
not gonna come back like make it work so
I'm still here so that's great you're
making it work were there people on vine
because the same way when I moved here
from New York I was doing here from New
York well from New Jersey in the name
you know Jersey New Jersey yeah it's
hilarious so everybody shits on New
Jersey yeah and I just think it's the
most ridiculous state I've never been
there so I don't I can't [ __ ] on it but
I I said it that way because I knew no
you can it's par for the course I [ __ ]
on it enough I know it's silly and dumb
and wonderful cuz it's so dumb I need to
go there it's also like so small in
comparison to Pennsylvania they have
White Castle there yes I think they do
do they do you not have it there no do
you whoa
no okay then you gotta go to Jersey I
think I'm gonna go to White Castle when
I was in New York there wasn't any
youtubers every all the youtubers are
starting to like build their themselves
out in LA and so coming out to LA I was
so excited to meet all these people that
I correspondent with online yeah felt
like I knew but had never really
physically met before did you have
Viners that you like linked up with when
you got out here yeah definitely um yeah
it was like a great migration like it
was seriously like 2012 through like
2015 was just like yeah that's everybody
from the internet came to LA yeah and a
lot of people still aren't here a lot of
people had to like couldn't hack it yeah
which is like you know survival of the
fittest we made it
dabbe yeah I'm 33
no I'm not that's all gonna lie I'm 45
Jesus that crazy tell your sister grace
is 45 you know she's really young I know
it's really swear on this yeah okay so
yeah so you get out here and then now
have you been you've been doing like
stand-up now I've done it three times
you should three three stand-ups I get
really nervous I like kind of like
blackout on stage honestly it's the one
thing I'm the most scared to do I've
never done it because I've done shows
with my friends like live stuff I've
done live podcast and that I've done
improv forever
stand-up is the thing that I'm like
still too scared to like break the seal
on it's like yeah I mean it's well I'm
finding out that all the all the cliches
people say about hard work or anything
like that's true you just have to like
[ __ ] do it there's literally no way
around it other than just put yeah put
the time in yeah and it's like yeah I
went to this open mic and it was there
was no audience members just other
people other comedians at the open mic I
got like two laughs and I like I like
thought this one joke was in a hit and
it didn't I like [ __ ] could not
remember to be fair if your audience is
only other open my kurz then it's not
gonna be generous laughter because
everyone's in their head right going
through what's true gonna be so they're
not really listening to you that's true
but yeah that's the thing that scares me
that most is like that kind of failure
mm-hmm me too
seriously like not getting a laugh and
then just be like so you're gonna keep
doing it oh yeah yeah it's very not
giving up that's great I'm never giving
up what's the endgame biggest comedian
and whole world oh wow all right I have
faith I think your worst or worse one of
the two yeah I think both are absolutely
attainable what's been
the biggest like who's your who are your
favorite comedians um I love Dave
Chappelle yeah i love i know louis c.k
is controversial okay but I still think
he's funny okay but I don't agree with
what he does yeah honestly I think
Chappelle is like me yeah that's so fun
just cuz his style of like observing and
um I don't know I watched an Amanda seal
stand up and she was really funny
actually she's hilarious I don't know
her yeah she's funny you should her news
special is called I be knowin oh cool
I'm gonna wash you with my girlfriend
and it was hilarious I'll have to check
that I've not seen it yet I'm honestly
like yeah it was funny as hell that's
very cool
no what do you watch TV wise other than
the bachelor with the girlfriend um also
who are you rooting for the bachelor d
are you rooting for one for Colton
you're you're rooting for Colton
sorry I'm still getting acquainted with
like how the whole thing works
yeah which girl am i rooting for yeah if
there is one tasia is cool okay remember
I'm like I don't think I can say that if
my girlfriend sees this she's gonna be
like what the hell I don't think I don't
think I'm rooting for anybody okay you
want them all to find love
yeah I just want it all to work with
them all to find that person that they
show up into the arms of which is my
favorite trope on the show that they do
is that every time they meet him they
jump into each other's eyes hi can I
steal you for a second they always look
so good to you never see like anybody
with like mustard in the corner of their
mouth they're very conscious but also
they've been given like a stipend to get
clothes for and like they get paid oh
that's a good question I don't think so
no there no I don't think so I think
they get their phones taken away they
get their accommodations provided they
get like food and obviously an enormous
amount of liquor the whole time that
they're there oh yeah I heard that yeah
they're just pumping them with booze
however Nick Viall was just on our show
he was one of the former bachelors and
he said that he's like liquors available
if you want to partake in it but some
people don't because they understand how
the show works and there's always gonna
be a focus on the drunkest person there
so it's pretty conscious but usually
someone lets it slip and those are the
best moments those are the best moments
and clearly they are up like all night
long during their like elimination
ceremony so they're all just glassy-eyed
waiting to be called to get a rose
that's the funniest thing is watching
them just kind of like if there was a
reality show that you would want to go
on what would it be one that already
exists like a survivor or big brother or
prices right well I guess those are
gameshow it's real they get the prizes
kind of think of something that like
it's a poor answer make it an afraid
would be sick oh man I would not I'm
totally confident with my my body well
that's only half the battle you have to
survive with no food no I don't think
I'd be able to survive so you just wanna
be naked and the other person kind of
survival did the naked guy there you go
starving okay which Rugrats baby would
you most interest to bail you out of
jail
I feel like yeah or Chucky Chuck he's
too nice he wouldn't do that
yeah check you might be a dork and not
be able to figure out how he's like I
can't do that totally what I did he's
not like a rule breaker Tommy could but
he's like Tommy would be in jail with
you really if you like you think the
moral compass of the show you know he'd
be like you can't do that man that's
against the law
then feel ya know probably has like a
shank in his film will always were
pulling like crusty lollipops out of
their day
and I'm glad that you had just an
immediate answer as if you might have
thought about this question okay we will
have more questions again so we're going
to take a quick break but when we get
back ma'am I have so many questions okay
we'll be right back with more Nicoletti
I'm not too deep right after this this
episode of not too deep is brought to
you by Macari do you have a bunch of
stuff lying around the house that you
just don't use a pair of jeans that you
only wear once an old phone hiding in a
drawer somewhere while Macari is an app
that you can use to sell all that junk
stuff I mean junk might have a negative
connotation stuff that's more positive
they make it fast and easy to sell
almost anything simply take a few pics
of your stuff add a description and boom
your item is listed and once it's sold
my car emails you a shipping label and
you just send it off so there's no
meetups with strangers there's my
favorite thing in the universe no
hassles with Macari you can sell
everything from fashion to electronics
toys to Sporting Goods over 100,000
items get listed on Macari every day and
earn a few extra dollars clean up the
valuable space in your home with Macari
the app has over 300,000 reviews on the
App Store and an average 4.8 start
rating so why not give it a try don't
let that stuff you don't use go to waste
sell it ship it and get paid with Macari
you can find Macari on the App Store
that's em e are c a.o i Macari the
selling app or go to Macari calm this
episode of not too deep is brought to
you by our dear friends at Squarespace
they make it easier than ever to launch
your passion project if you're looking
to start a new business showcase your
work publish content
sell products and more they are the tool
for you they have beautiful templates
created by world-class designers and the
ability to customize just about anything
with a few clicks you can easily make a
beautiful website all by yourself plus
they have powerful ecommerce
functionality which lets you sell
anything online and analytics they help
you grow your site in real time and
everything is optimized for mobile right
on the box you don't to overthink it
there's nothing to patch or upgrade ever
whatever that
mean that don't even know buying domains
is simple and you'll get the help you
need with Squarespace is 24/7
award-winning customer support they
empower millions of people from
designers to lawyers artists gamers
restaurants gyms etc etc to turn great
ideas into something real head to
squarespace.com slash grace for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain that squarespace.com slash great
offer code grace yeah quick thoughts on
the Rugrats movies amazing really
genuinely yeah okay even if they're not
I mean it was just like a part of my
childhood so yeah were you big into like
new cartoons mm-hmm Oh like Rocko's
Modern Life all those not really okay
never mind not Rocko's Modern Life
Oh which ones were you into The Wild
Thornberrys I forgot about them yeah
don't think it's the parents that go to
like the outback and the kids go yeah
they like travel all over the world and
the one the daughter can talk to animals
that's right there was a lot going on in
that it was cool her son yeah Donny he
was like crazy yes yes
and then Darwin was the chimpanzee who
cut also or he could understand a lot of
course of course of course
I mean imagine coming up with that show
you have a lot of character like dynamic
also it's so smart like an adult could
watch it at the same time is like
spongebob are you a spongebob for total
yeah yeah I was years and years and
years when I first came out and then um
yeah I I got like into high school it's
for babies and then it became like
ironic as an adult too like spongebob
and like everyone was wearing spongebob
shirts and stuff and now it's back to
like okay it's fun I actually watched my
like the show I remember watching it
when I was like babysitting my cousins
when I was like in high school and being
like this is [ __ ] up but they're like
loving it that is like some yeah what
there's layers so like adults see it a
different way than the kid sees yeah
totally okay how has Fame changed you I
wouldn't
I always like it I'm not famous yeah
yeah I do get recognized it's it's great
I mean my fans are my fans are awesome
everyone's really respectful like hey
Nick like have you ever had a very
strange fan interaction yeah I mean I
mean it's just like within any person
you know everybody's different some
people kind of like are a little too
like yeah they come in hot which is like
okay cool but it's like come on dude but
for the most part yeah everyone's really
cool respectful like mature like I think
I thought you said like my church my
church everyone's really respectful like
my church yeah I just I I mean I don't
know yeah like I said I wouldn't
consider myself like sadness is fun but
what's a little bit of Fame that I have
yeah I just try to stay like yeah chill
talk talking to my family just kind of
grounds me so no that's great to talk to
them like as often as I can my cousins
especially they'll be like hey Nick
you're a [ __ ] idiot wait oh that's
good that keep you level yeah when you
yeah I was gonna say when you go home
for the holidays whatever like will you
put me in your seriously like I love my
family so much have you had a fanboy
moment of anyone out here while you've
been out in LA that you've either seen
in an event or like on the street I
guess I think I saw John Mayer walking
down the street just been a guy who
looked like John Mayer dark-haired
handsome man carrying a guitar just
singing um not really I mean the like if
I saw Leo DiCaprio or someone like that
I've never seen a famous person not
famous yeah those people are like rare
like never seen like legendary yeah like
what do they do during the day like
where do they go like no one ever sees
them yeah because we're like we're just
out in the public floppy and I saw Jay
Leno one time you did yeah I was
crossing the street and he was yawn
and then I like double took and I was
like wait hold on and then he like stop
Yanni and I was like yawning in a car
yeah using a blue Tesla of course Mary
Jay Leno it was in van nuys - and I was
like dude what the [ __ ] are you doing
here that's what they all are they're
all in van nuys then I guess I just walk
out on your street more okay which of
your vines would you never want quoted
ever again what the [ __ ] is a cow I
don't know the yeah how do you put up
with that I mean you put out so much are
there ones that you've taken down later
and been like I can't this is the
dumbest thing I hate this oh yeah
definitely
yeah like curate my feed yeah once in a
while yeah I mean but also your
Instagram is all over the place it is
which I appreciate that aesthetic but
there is no aesthetic it's just like
whatever I'm feeling yeah it's um it's
very curious what's your like how do you
know when something's good enough to
post on your Instagram honestly I delete
a lot of my pics do you really I like
post it and if it doesn't do as well as
I wanted to do monitor yeah really
samadeva oh you put off the persona that
you don't give a [ __ ] I know right
you're good thanks
yeah I mean I care I mean I don't know
yeah who do you follow on Instagram
that's like okay two questions one who
do you love to follow on Instagram and
two you don't fancy this one but who do
you hate follow on Instagram why mute
I've mute everybody muted because I
don't like to look at people [ __ ] cuz it
[ __ ] ruins my whole day so I just
muted everybody even your friends yeah I
don't literally all my whole feet is
just stuff that I impose yes because I
don't like going on Instagram I just
don't like okay cool yeah I mean so you
don't generally and I don't hate anybody
on Instagram either cuz I don't just
like looking at your own stuff not even
that I just like posting and then just
getting out cuz like being there yeah
being on Instagram is there any social
media platform that you
enjoy not really anymore really everyone
just [ __ ] ruined everything like
seriously it's true it's a little bit
toxic now quit Twitter's fun to just say
what you want and then same thing just
like do what you got to do and then
leave like get off the app and I looked
at your Twitter what's this chowman tap
name Oh Joe yeah it's actually from a
video of this kid who always goes up to
this other kid and the kids like hey
what's up man the kids just like ciao he
walks away started ending tweet it's
like very a sophisticated yeah it's very
european with the with the tilde yeah a
little squiggle ciao I didn't know if
that was like internet jargon that I had
missed I didn't know if it was like lmao
mm-hmm but it see I am yeah chilling in
a orange yeah done figured it out yeah
your Twitter is really funny cuz it does
look like just stream-of-consciousness
whatever you're thinking at the moment
thank you but then people love it and I
said there'd I try and think of like
jokes for two hours I can't do it and
then I just get off just gonna let it go
just let them let the memes flow through
you are you starting this new breed of
spirituality
internet-based I think that might be
what the world needs right now I kind of
think it does some sort of reprieve from
all of that
get away what's the worst you ever did
on a school test f yeah I was not very
good in school yeah it was there any
class that you liked in school um math
was cool that's math interesting to me
yeah and my teacher I had a really cool
teacher mr. Jonker he's a huge fan of
the podcast yes yeah it he had all these
transformers and he would bring them
into class it was like kind of really
weird but he's cool he meant well
twelve you just bring in toys yeah he
knew what he was doing it's kind of
weird
whatever you're talking about him how
many years later yeah I had an impact
and I think they appreciate in value so
he's the one laughing at us a lot of
them that's and did he use them to teach
you math no or just for decorous to have
him yeah a collector yeah you guys know
that he's cool yeah you guys check these
on 18 that's cool in your [ __ ] weird
did you collect anything growing up
Mighty Beanz what are those these little
bean things little characters on them
they're really stupid Mighty Beanz like
Mighty Ducks mmm they're beans they're
literally okay
they're little plastic like beans okay
with the ball bearing inside of it like
like then bobbled around yeah but there
was like rare ones and like okay and you
just bought them yeah cool where they
know gone Oh somewhere far away
do you remember Mighty Beanz bring back
the mummies
no one I talked to them about people and
they're like I don't know what that
you're talking you might have just
dreamt this is it a Mandela effect maybe
it could be everyone whether you've
actually heard of Mighty Beanz or not
I know beanie babies it wasn't that okay
what are you working on next what's
coming up what are you working on now
trying to I guess I'm trying to
transition from the Internet to
traditional traditional yeah yeah kind
of tough yeah do you get the stereotype
a lot of like you're an Internet kid
Drive yeah this is so they D legitimize
like you being funny and you have like
that actual talent to do that yeah I
actually went to a audition and they
were like he has no clue what he's doing
they said that out loud - you know they
wrote it in an email and I was like okay
I guess this isn't for me but wait they
wrote in an email to you directly no -
to the agent that booked it for me
but I was like damn okay I guess I have
a lot I mean I just have a lot of work
to do like I want to put in all the work
and yeah but also no one ever knows what
they're doing unless someone tells them
right you know that's how I felt I still
feel like I've been auditioning for
years and I still feel like I go into a
room and I've no [ __ ] clue what I'm
doing mm-hmm and no one the truth be
told no one knows what they're doing
yeah even like actors and actresses that
have been in classes specifically
designed to teach you how auditioning
how you should audition you go in and
every casting directors different
everyone is different there's no
rulebook for it so struck that person if
you don't know what you're doing yeah I
mean I feel like it was a good wake-up
call I'm like okay why I want to learn
more and uh I actually had an
interesting conversation with my manager
after cuz I actually left an audition I
was like I totally bitched out I like
god I psyched myself out I got afraid I
[ __ ] left yeah and my agent was like
dude where the [ __ ] are you and long
story short I just overthought it and my
manager was like you don't know what
they're looking for ever like that you
could be you just have to play it just
the way you you think you should play
the character like that's that's the
only rule that was the biggest
game-changer for me too I was of the
same mindset that I'm like I have to go
in and act a character like not myself
and then some casting director was like
you just come in and be yourself right
and they'll either want that or they
won't one second I'm like is that a
worse like getting no then they don't
want me but they also the other thing
too that I've heard is that if you don't
feel like you're gonna do well in the
audition don't audition because you'd
rather not give them a bad impression
instead give them no impression right
yeah ghost them right let them know that
you're leaving yeah but yeah you can't
you can't go in with like trying to
please them and like yeah doing like
this is what I think they want you you
have to like be like this is who I think
it's like dating this cashier guy is
like exactly literally dating that you
can't go into a date going I think this
girl's gonna like this type of guy so
I'll pretend I like be certain I think
it's exactly like
yeah just have to do your thing if they
[ __ ] with you boom
[ __ ] [ __ ] um do you remember your very
first tweet no well we have your we have
an answer your very first tweet was weed
that actually wasn't my very first week
oh well it deleted like hella tweets so
I made sure that that was the first so
you cure so then you know so you lied
you deleted all your first beats because
they were embarrassing
yeah just like being a stupid kid okay
yeah that makes sense so now when people
go back to your first tweet it just says
weed well you caught us you pranked us
so they'll know we did it okay which
Marvel superhero do you think has the
best chance of that you have the best
chance of winning a verbal argument with
is the Hulk Marvel yeah okay but if you
get him mad he'll Hulk out true and then
I'll get killed by the Hulk yeah but
still yo and I would have made him so
mad that he killed me
is there super here that you'd most want
to be killed by I don't know home the
whole like rip me off or something Hulk
smash Hulk smash yeah you'll get smashed
I want him to smash me
can you imagine playing smash your past
with the Hulk he will smash you never
pass no never pass you is there are you
into like superhero franchises and that
sort of thing I wasn't as a kid but I I
mean the movies are kind of interesting
now yeah they're like entertaining
what's the thing that you're into what's
what's it like what are your hobbies um
reading really sort of yeah okay I like
learning I like learning stuff what kind
of stuff are you reading and learning
about now um just like how money works
and like businesses and stuff oh cool
trying to like legitimize my whole
operation
ya know it sounds like you
putting in a lot of like self work this
yeah oh yeah let's go
do you have resolutions did you make
resolutions this year yeah not really
that but that's okay I want to do better
than I did last year that's that's my
reason I think that's a solid resolution
for everyone and so you're learning how
to like become an entrepreneur yeah not
so much not so much learning how to
become an entrepreneur more like how to
because if you're self-employed you're
self-employed yeah that manage your
finances right do all the [ __ ] ourselves
like make sure I'm not like cutting any
corners getting my taxes on there yeah
taxes are the big thing to make sure
that you don't get audited in any way
yeah because that's a big saving for the
future because we don't have like a
nine-to-five that puts money aside for
us we have to like be conscious fast
yeah all that stuff so are you investing
in stocks not I haven't made any
investments yet but I think I'm probably
like me I don't know okay maybe real
estate yeah no that's what I learned in
the last couple years that's like the
best investment that you can put your
money into cuz I don't have I'm not like
a some millionaire dude who has like all
this money to like cuz the stocks are
stock scare mix I don't know how that
market works right yeah but real estate
I've started to figure it out yeah it's
like people pay you to live there and
you get the money in it's sick so you
should teach a class okay guys it's
really easy
what did cousin Charlie think of the
Super Bowl this year he thought it was
pissed
it's [ __ ] piss mates
it was really boring yeah I can't
imagine being there in person watching
it on TV was boring and they didn't give
my man Travis enough time on the stage
oh yeah I only got to play like a
snippet of his song yeah yeah I know
that the whole it was all kind of
disappointing mm-hmm yeah I mean why
Adam Levine like dude come on we're at
that done it she's like whatever dude
yeah it's like I don't want to see if
I've seen maroon 5 like a [ __ ]
million I've heard their songs a million
times like see I've never seen them live
and he sounded ill he's on it's sick
like but like actually sick like
actually like his throat with something
was wrong I was like is something wrong
and I shouldn't be noticing this because
I know nothing about maroon 5 but it
seems to be the collective sentiment of
everyone that watched it
what would what's your dream Superbowl
halftime show
gucci mane
yeah and future and Travis cotton like
just a huge like hip-hop blowout no more
pop anything no maroon 5 no no but dude
you can't say that the Lady Gaga
halftime show is bad I didn't see it I
don't even know what that is
Oh give yourself some time and go check
it out good huh it's great it's great
and she's like she's just a great
performer dancer she's a great spectacle
yes Italian that is also true yeah you
guys at your Italian mmm well there you
go you might be related maybe who knows
yeah she's an Italian lesson parents on
like a restaurant in New York called Liu
was her album called with her with the
hat on Joanne
yeah it's Joanne's maybe Joanne sir ant
or something I don't know who knows
we're just spouting nonfacts right now
we're gonna take one last break and we
get back we have a bunch of Twitter
questions for you and they're there
they're very fun are they beefy they're
beefy they're Stewie holy Sh I'll be
right back with more not YouTube right
after this this episode is brought to
you by at Lisa they believe that a bed
is more than just a place to sleep it's
a place for relaxation and rest they
believe that everybody has the right to
rest and that's where they make to
awesome mattresses plus accessories and
bases to give your body the deep rest it
needs the all foam Lisa mattress is new
and improved featuring cooling LS a 200
film for enhanced pressure relief for
side sleepers and their superior hybrid
mattress is the perfect combination of
foam and spring for pressure relief and
edge to edge support
Lisa's mission is to provide a better
night's sleep for everybody from day one
Lisa sets out to create a company with
heart and that's why they donate one man
for every 10 they sell to organizations
that work in causes like foster care
prevention to date they've donated more
than 32 thousand mattresses for more
than 1,000 nonprofits this is amazing
company they sent me a mattress I
absolutely love it
I can't say enough good things about it
so please get on it guys and you can get
15% off your entire order at Lisa comm
sash grace use the promo code grace
that's Ellie esa.com slash grace promo
code grace okay we're back okay Nick
we're gonna get into Twitter questions
before we do I'm gonna ask you the two
questions asked every single guest that
is on the podcast and the first is who
alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti at oh okay
you can take your time and think about
it who alive or dead would you most want
to throw cold spaghetti at it doesn't
have to be a malicious thing it can be a
celebratory thing it can be an uplifting
thing it can be a hey just please pay
attention to does it have to be a real
person no it can be a fictitious
character the world is your oyster yeah
it is a tough question it's the most
hard-hitting question we have on this
whole [ __ ] is it actually I mean yes and
no it doesn't have to be this tough I
know I'm really thinking about yeah I
can see you're truly considering it
which I appreciate that you're really
really imagining that this is gonna
happen later today and you want to make
the right choice um probably um I was
gonna say Trump yeah
that's what Jimmy said - we've had a lot
of Trump Trump's yeah
which makes no sense I'm cool with that
and at this point if he gets that amount
of cold spaghetti on him for every
answer that we've had that's Trump and
very very happy with it
okay the other question or ask is to
tell us the your worst pants [ __ ]
story or close call but you can only use
three words or three small phrases so
mine is college jogging front lawn
neighbors
New Year's
that's my panties day Wow I love when
someone has an answer immediately and
doesn't have to think about it that's my
favorite it was a shart
it was yeah it was bad we've heard many
many sort of philosophies have never
trust the fart
never trust a shirt or never trust the
fart because it could be a shart put it
in a pillow so that's it okay someone to
know is there gonna be a season three of
the real boroughs of Simi Valley and if
there is can you please add Casey Frei I
don't know if there's gonna be a third
season I seriously doubt my mom has been
like grilling me about that mom loves it
yeah that's great and I could talk to
Jimmy about seeing I think we were
talking about Casey being involved yeah
I don't know what I need a text Jimmy
basically well he was just here we kind
of relayed a message what was it I'm
this is a question for me not from
Twitter what was it like shooting cuz
you K you shot with some like big-name
actors know that your dad is when I'm
blinking the actor's name Chris
Christopher McDonald yeah how was that
it was awesome he's seems so scary
it kind of was but um he's just a really
cool guy and kind of like I had a lot of
questions about acting he like took the
time to answer them and I saw him at the
the wrap party and he was like made a
big deal about coming over and saying
what's up so yeah I mean he he's like a
huge star but he's still really just
down there and then Paul Scheer was in
like the last episode right hilarious
yeah he's so funny and he's also
extremely nice which is kind of
off-putting in a way because he's like
has so many accolades and I'm just like
how are you this nice he's super
accomplished out of it they had a lot of
really great really great actors on it
this season so yeah how was it because
Jimmy was mentioned you guys got to
improvise I'm just sort of like do your
own thing
yeah that's honestly what's like the
most fun about it is
um we just have fun and like do the
scene like with the skeleton that they
give us like the script and then all the
extra [ __ ] that we just come up with
like Jimmy will be like that's hilarious
like maybe not like you know yeah it's
very like yeah if they like something
they'll just they'll throw it in so it's
awesome
do you've a moment that you remember as
your favorite yeah on the finale when
we're all flicking each other off at the
hand that was totally in front of like
me and Jimmy like yeah we just like it
was one of those moments where we were
all on the same page and it just because
then a few weeks ago that whole viral
video the two kids
flipping each other off that everyone
thought was real like in the streets of
New York and then it became it was two
people that were doing it like I planned
it and then I saw your finale and I was
like wait a minute they shot this before
that came yeah yeah I want I mean I
don't know maybe this maybe they stole
it no I don't think they did that scene
is so funny the whole fight scene in
that last episode is so funny thank you
um are you familiar with simi valley um
I have been there okay so the
stereotypes in which you guys are
playing accurate I I honestly haven't
spent enough time to know but I have met
people who are from there and they're
like yeah it's 100% accurate dude yeah I
was gonna say to people from see me come
up to you ever mm-hmm and they think
it's I haven't met anyone who's like
[ __ ] you man it's not the way it is man
no guilty pleasures if I'm allowed to
talk about um I don't know smoking a
[ __ ] load of weed and like eating a
bunch of food okay at night that just
seems like a pleasure it doesn't feel
guilty well I don't know my my
girlfriend like doesn't like okay my
girlfriend doesn't like that it do
anything ever
FaceTime her and talk to her hey I mean
it works
I feel like sneak away and smoke and
like eat a cheeseburger real quick and
then she'll be like Nick we're watching
The Bachelor let's go
so nice of you that you agreed to watch
The Bachelor especially this season
which sucks so um it's not easy let me
tell you it's not easy to get through it
I mean one thing that she could do for
you to reciprocate the you watching The
Bachelor nothing she's the best I love
her so much
that's incredibly sweet people don't
know she gets really mad about that all
right
I'm private like I don't I don't like to
put all my stuff out there no that's
good do you make a conscious effort to
like have a like a private life yeah I
mean well I don't know cuz I go back and
forth on like how much I put out on the
internet because once you put it out
there you can't take it back right yeah
I mean with my family and my
relationships I I like to keep that
stuff private cuz it's like that's
that's for you
yeah and I don't want people judging
anybody or heckling any my family
members are like [ __ ] with any my
people that I actually care about yeah I
definitely try to protect no that's
incredibly she gets mad at me she's like
well he pissed me nobody knows that were
dating oh so she wants it she really
does yeah oh I wish we fight a lot about
oh I thought she didn't want you talking
about she's like you should be proud of
me you need to put me on you and I'm
like okay no okay she works um she works
in television so okay she's like a PA on
the show gosh you got it about yeah
she's awesome I love her she's how'd you
guys meet
it's done really did you slide into the
sugar mine yeah we headed off and yeah
she's the best how long have you guys
been together about two years now
Wow so sliding into dams does work it
does Wow okay she's never know ladies
take know you never know lids take take
just uh I mean she's way ballsier than I
am so I don't slide into DMS cuz I can't
deal with rejections
there you go so you just wait for it I
just wait I'm like one of those like
what the catcher's mitt filter fish that
just like lets all those bacteria past
strands okay someone to know do you ever
feel like you need matches to keep your
eyes open yeah yeah is this a thing yeah
okay got it
I was like is this related to a vine at
all whatsoever
super obscure okay interesting I'm
supposed to know what's Bing Bing bong
bong mean I have not either yeah I don't
know okay something bad something dirty
probably also someone's no generally
just how's your day going [ __ ]
awesome yeah really the rest of the day
we're just chill you know I had this and
this is great and then uber back to Van
Nuys oh hell yeah so like a five-hour
uber suite in the rain it rains nice and
I like the ramp yeah because you're from
the east coast shake it up boom
so are you yeah I mean but I don't I
don't miss the rain mm-hmm isn't that a
song I don't miss the rain do you ever
change the rain who's that
yeah something like that something like
that what do you miss most about
Pittsburgh my mom your mom I love you
mom yeah the greatest thing Pittsburgh
has ever done in my opinion is make
sandwiches with french fries on them
[ __ ] yeah
thank you you're welcome yeah good job
consolidate yeah you can never stand
what you're gonna fries anyway put them
all together make it to go Steelworkers
feed him somehow what's the greatest
thing like the thing that you've learned
on the set of see me um to show up on
time really treat it like a job yeah
yeah okay I feel like a lot of people
get uh
[Music]
the ego thing it's like we're all still
we're trying to make this [ __ ] work okay
so yeah just leave that [ __ ] at home
like show up on time and [ __ ] work
that's great yeah cuz it does I think
people get in their own heads about like
we're all fun and having a good time and
we're all becoming friends and this is
flexible so it's okay if I'm ten minutes
late but the ship can't leave unless
everyone's on board right and people
taken out of that chair too so yeah they
do
being respectful showing up on time I'm
like and I'm so bad at that and then I
will be in a situation where someone's
like to show up for something I'm
involved in it I'm there on time and I
get so mad at them and I'm like oh [ __ ]
this is how people feel when I show up
right and I assume that like it'll be
fine well it's fine no that's a
seemingly like simple lesson but
something that I don't think people take
for yourself I mean I'm I've been guilty
of it too like [ __ ] it i'm i'm nick
colletti I'm not to show up but yeah I
mean it's just like the director is
gonna be like okay where the [ __ ] is
this guy yeah everybody slows everything
down so yeah and then they clock it and
then if you have to work on stuff with
them in the future they're like that guy
like that guy never showed up on time
yeah and there's gonna be guess what
20,000 other actors that can do what you
do that will show up on time right take
it with a great oh no don't take with a
grain of salt take it that's true
Nick thank you so much for being here
and for having before we wrap up
completely we give every guest that's
made time for us at the podcast a
personalized fortune cookie
oh wow that you're welcome to open and
read what's inside this is safe can I
open it yeah up here yeah you can ASMR
the noise mm-hmm Oh what about the
crumbs it's okay
we'll fix it that was a good one okay
it's in here mm-hmm
should I like break it more go for it
[Laughter]
how did you guys do this all right let's
see what it is oh I don't even remember
what this is okay oh my god it's so
awesome 20 19 is the year of you finally
ballin with your bros please proceed to
ball into ball hard
failing to ball hard
to your fullest may result in banishment
from future ballin activities oh yes
tell us about bomb with your bros it's
been a ride yeah it's been a hell of a
ride yeah good you got merch out right
yeah yeah we took it a little too far no
I like explain for people that don't
know what this is
it was just a video that we we were
actually sick of like all the Instagram
like we're just like [ __ ] it we think
too much about it let's just like do
this really quick and whatever comes
like yeah be whatever so we shot the
video super quick Casey went and edited
it had to did it that was the result we
uploaded it and then yeah I mean kind of
popped off so yeah how long ago was that
it's probably like a month and a half
maybe less okay I know when the merch
strapped maybe like two weeks after Oh
amazing and it's still available right
oh yeah okay where can people find the
merch fan joy dot CEO slash Nick there
you go so mad at my job yeah my job
awesome where can people find you and
everything that you're doing online if
they don't already know um all my
socials are just at Nick underscore
Coletti all of them yeah great and if
you live in the los angeles area
i mean pay attention to your twitter
because you might be dropping in at open
mic scenes here and there definitely
will be go check him out so that someone
in the audience laughs yeah right no one
will it's cool thank you again really
appreciate it
we'll see you guys next time on another
episode of not too deep goodbye deep
deep deep this episode of not too deep
has been brought to you by Macario
Macario is the selling app that makes it
fast and easy to sell almost anything
you just take a few pics at a
description and bow mat your item is
listed with buyers in all 50 states
stuff really cells and everything ships
easily so there are never any awkward
meetups you could find Macari on the App
Store
Macari com that's M er C AR i.com check
it out not too deep is a production of
grace helbig incorporated producer and
edited by melissa demons writing by
Diane Kang a production assistants by
Katrina Henning post-production sound by
Christopher Bell and an extra special
thanks to Flula for the theme music
[Music]